Governor Brown thank you so much for
being here it's really great to have you
here is this your first time on
Bloomberg Television ok sometimes ok
well it's great to have you back
so california's jobless rate is falling
faster than any other state in the
nation including texas the the most
comparable large state how do you
sustain and if even increased that
momentum
well we how do you plan on doing that by
building on what we have on Silicon
Valley and Viacom in so many parts of
the state especially San Diego and
Orange County the great agriculture the
universities UC Stanford Cal Tech USC
there's a variety of modern pillars that
drive the economy forward
we're also on the Pacific we have great
ports that are almost 40% of the trade
of America and wherever you look and and
we have all the immigration coming in so
at every level of the modern economy
California is present and what we have
to do of course is to keep that balance
keep encouraging innovation but also
make sure that we work to reduce
inequality protect the environment and
really sustain this tremendous burst of
energy and investment now California has
one of the highest average incomes in
the country and it's going up faster
than any other state but it's creating a
serious wealth divide nearly one in six
people in California live in poverty
what are you doing to address that well
what we're doing a course is directing
our school funds to those areas that
have greater challenges of low income
families families that don't speak
English foster care kids we have what we
call the local control spending formula
where we reduce regulations and increase
spending based on the need that the
students have that's it's a very novel
formula but I don't believe any other
state has so that's important we also
have the state Earned Income Tax Credit
we also have
our Medicaid program which we call
medical we provide a full health care
program which we now provide to 12
million people we've increased it 50% it
just in the last three years we also
have a very massive program to assist
low-income people in taking care of
their parents or the disabled in their
family so we have a very rich and
pervasive safety net now is it up to the
global engine of both wealth and
inequality
I'd say the global economy is moving
faster but I think we're doing a very
credible job but of course there's
always more to do now you were born and
raised in San Francisco you know how
much the city has changed you know how
expensive it has become the tech
community in particular has been blamed
for widening inequality increasing
income inequality is that fair and if so
what should the tech community do about
it well everything you do has a downside
there are some parts of America that are
stagnant that their principal industry
left and there's mass unemployment and
and kids leave and it's quite depressing
California has the other problem
everybody wants to come here and low
income people from all over the world
very highly educated people investors
tech people they come to California so
given the limited amount of space
particularly along the coast that drives
up prices so that is a problem that
we're coping with we have to build more
more housing I'm also building but the
only high-speed rail in the Western
Hemisphere and that high-speed rail will
be able to take people from Silicon
Valley in a matter of minutes to parts
of California where rent and housing is
much cheaper and I would say that would
do quite a lot as well as we raise a
little wage we provide benefits sick
leave and other things to try to make
the work experience as best we can
at the same time encouraging innovation
encouraging investment and making sure
that the dynamism of California
continues so it is a balancing act and
there will never be a perfect moment
there's always an issue but I would say
a rather deal with California's problems
which are the problems of affluence and
innovation and diversity than the
problems of stagnation and being in some
economic backwater but do you think the
tech community in particular bears some
responsibility for this and if so should
they be doing more certainly when
someone has a company their job is to
make the proper investments take care of
their shareholders and their employees
and the community in which their that
and we and our job in government is to
pass laws to set the bar at a reasonable
level I think we're doing that and the
trouble is the wealth is growing so
quickly that the prices are moving up
very quickly and that is something
that's very difficult government can't
say alright hold down prices we're going
to regulate everything cuz that would
throw the baby out with the bathwater
we're dealing with a difficult situation
I would say there's probably no place in
California that has more of a safety net
more of compensatory initiatives by
government but everything
balance and this is a pretty
freewheeling investment environment and
you're always going to have excesses and
where we see a sensible way to curtail
accesses we certainly want us a day to
do that now you have some experience
presidential campaigning you ran for
president three times what is your take
on this election we've seen the
establishment candidates on the right
and to some degree on the Left rejected
by many voters how does this play out
well I think the problem is the position
that America is in our position in the
world the growing gap between the rich
and the poor all these things create
tension and people want an answer and
unfortunately it's very hard to have an
answer when government is completely
divided people in Washington can't
govern because they're divided between
Republicans and Democrats conservatives
and liberals religious fundamentalists
libertarians and all the rest so we have
a crisis of governance in the face of an
increasingly difficult and dangerous
world and people are upset and I have to
tell you the the campaign's in the
candidacies are not all that inspiring
but it's very difficult to be inspiring
in the midst of this kind of challenge
in complexity so I symbolize for the
candidates and I would just say they're
gonna have to do better to win the
support of the American people now some
are saying that California's primary
could be the Republicans last stand the
establishments last stand in preventing
Donald Trump from winning the nomination
is is that nomination inevitable no it's
not inevitable mr. Trump doesn't have a
majority like everything else
things happen in unpredictable ways he's
doing remarkably well but it's not he
doesn't have a majority so there's a lot
to be stay tuned there's much more to
happen I certainly wouldn't want to
predict what's gonna happen in
California it's very open
I'd say anybody can win this thing does
it scare you though that he's that close
to the nomination and
and thus to the president well I don't
like to say I'm scared by these
candidates there's a lot of things I'm
more concerned about I'm concerned about
the big issues facing America and the
inability of the Republican and
Democratic leadership to get together
whether it's on a Supreme Court nominee
whether it's the finance of roads and
bridges
whether it's increase our research and
development or if it's the deal with the
the negative consequences of
globalization in the form of inequality
I'd like that to happen the president
with all the hoopla is going to
disappoint people because if we have a
dysfunctional Congress ultimately people
are going to get mad at the president
and so I think it's we're all in this
together and I sort of would like to do
Mike my part to make it more positive
political environment who are you
supporting I'm less worried about this
point if if would you accept a VP
nomination I haven't offered one I don't
accept
what I have no would you be interested
not particularly
why no well because I ran for president
not vice versa
how do you see the race playing out them
I don't predict I'm not a Jesus figure
I'd say you see it demise I'd say it was
very strong and I'd say the Republican
Party hasn't quite gelled yet but it's
getting close to shelling jelly ground
Trump where it just well it's getting
close to gelling so you know events
happen in politics scandals occur
untoward events comments made and you
never I mean it is look like it's
shaping up into I mean it looks like
it's coming together but I'd wait a bit
longer before we try to lock things down
say now we know who the nominees are
right I give us a few more months it's
Donald Trump fit to be President
yeah I would say the idea that he's
gonna build a wall and make Mexico pay
for it is absolutely preposterous and
would create such tension where their
closest neighbor that probably a dumber
idea I can't imagine or maybe a de Namur
Dean yes it's dumber than it is
dangerous
now for the top ten companies by market
are in California but of course you've
got other states other cities around the
world trying to be the next Silicon
Valley how do you make sure that Silicon
Valley continues to be the place where
top talent is cultivated Silicon Valley
didn't happen overnight
you can't just come here you know drink
the water and take it home and think
you're gonna create staying for an Apple
and Facebook and hewlett-packard doesn't
work that way the evolution in this area
has come through world war two the
aerospace industry and the information
technology the space industries and the
internet all that that has been building
based on the California system of higher
education the openness to new entrants
people come here and in a matter of
months they can find very important job
in a matter of years they've become CEO
and presidents and as a matter of fact
if you look at most of the governor's
with exception of myself and my father
in aura Warren they all moved here and
within a matter of a decade or two
they're running for higher office so
what that means we're very open and a
lot of these other places in the world
are not they're much more culturally
conservative so in that sense I think we
have a dynamism that we have to be very
careful to nurture but I'm not worried
about other people grabbing it it isn't
for sale and it's not really for
transfer this encryption debate going on
between Apple and the FBI has created an
even bigger divide between Silicon
Valley and Washington could Washington
be at risk of losing the support of its
biggest economic contributors well I
think we have to I'm not prepared to say
what the right answer on that is but I
do think I think terrorism is a it's
obviously a threat but what people
haven't talked about is nuclear
terrorism and the nuclear materials in
the world are so widespread and would be
so devastating if they were brought to
New York or Washington or any other
state or London or Moscow that we have
to be prepared to defang the terrorists
and
whether or not you can create an
encryption that no one can ever look at
that's the topic I I want to give some
real thoughts that I see mr. gates is on
one side mr. cook is on another and I'm
not prepared at least on this program
offer my wisdom because I think it takes
more knowledge than I have the sharing
economy has exploded especially in
California should companies like uber
make their drivers employee should they
be giving them benefits where do you
stand on this well I I think that you
you have to respect the the employment
relationship it's a matter now being
tested in the courts and we do have
rules in California that will be
interpreted by the courts so I think the
flexibility is very good but I think you
have to watch the exploitation of
workers and again like everything else
it's a balance the the apps and the the
flexible sharing economy is incredible I
would like to see that certainly protect
working people I'd like to see that
applied to the service industry I don't
know people keep saying a higher
education we just have to throw more
money I wish I could find some some
technology that would reduce the cost
while we expand the the access so this
is one we're gonna have to work out and
I'm not gonna work it out here but there
are some there's points where workers
have to have a sense of security but
this new amazing flexibility that is
provided we're going to try to combine
the the benefits of both the old-style
employment and the new style flexibility
it's not going to be all the way one way
all the other the other one we're gonna
find a balance
climate change may well define your
legacy you've had some success getting
support on the Republican side for your
policies what needs to be done to create
sustainable policies on a national scale
well we have to get some Republicans to
wake up to the fact that there is
something called climate change and it
takes a real effort it's gonna take
pricing carbon and some Republican
conservatives have called for a revenue
neutral carbon tax it's gonna take
investment in R&D so we can get zero
emission vehicle
California were already 25 percent
renewable energy
we're gonna go to 50 percent in 15 years
but this takes a national commitment and
the Supreme Court really dealt a blow to
America's leadership on this issue when
they struck down or at least temporarily
blocked Obama's clean clean air
initiative this is really important
climate change is real we're gonna have
to prepare for a sea-level rise of
anywhere from four to six feet by the
end of the century that's going to take
tens of billions hundreds of billions
and we got to work both in adaptation
and prevention through through renewable
and energy efficiency policy this is
damn serious a number of politicians
have their head in the sand and we have
to move forward with China with the u.s.
with Europe with other countries it's
it's a global challenge but America can
provide a lot of the leadership and the
initiative but pending Washington waking
up and getting off it's dysfunctionality
California is providing a real path
forward
we've developed a memorandum of
understanding with over a hundred and
twenty states provinces and even
countries so we are committed to
mobilizing countries around the world
and States to lower their carbon
footprint so we're not waiting but we
know we really can't get to the goal
without Washington and then Beijing and
Tokyo and all the other major countries
in the world
this is your last term as governor you
said you don't want to be VP how do you
want your legacy to be defined what do
you want to define your wish me I I
don't believe in legacies I really don't
it's a new that's a meme that has been
developed in the last 20 years I like to
take the problems as they exist but its
climate change high-speed rail water
efficiency schools to helping low income
people and making sure our colleges
aren't the best reforming our prison
system we've got a big big menu of
things to do so how that will be viewed
in 10 to 20 years you'll have to wait 10
or 20 years
but don't try to anticipate everything
will come in its own time California
Governor Jerry Brown thank you so much
for joining us today on the over
television great to have you great to
beer